où as-tu fait ma psyché ça va
nous avons presque glissé dans le paquet et ton
bas ventre et tu vas
transporter quelque chose de très spécial des thés
hé tu parles anglais non non non parle
anglais oui oui emmène moi à l'hôpital maintenant
quelqu'un a mis un  sac de drogue à l'intérieur de moi j'ai
besoin que vous le sortiez il fuit
on estime que la plupart des êtres humains n'utilisent que
10% de la capacité du cerveau Panaji si nous
pouvions accéder à 100% des choses intéressantes
commencent à se produire oui professeur Norman je
m'appelle Lucy je viens de lire  toutes vos
recherches sur le cerveau humain c'est un
peu rudimentaire mais vous êtes sur la
bonne voie
je vous remercie j'ai accès à 28% de ma
capacité cérébrale je ressens tout
depuis quand avez vous commencé à écrire le chinois il
n'y a pas
ce qui se passe quand elle  atteint 100% n'ont
aucune idée de toutes ces connaissances que vous pouvez
débloquer des secrets qui vont au-delà de notre
lumineux Je ne suis même pas sûr que l'humanité
soit prête pour
c'est comme si toutes les choses qui me rendent
humain s'effacent
toi